[Music]
did you guys hear about Jim Carrey
getting backlash for a recent comment he
made during an interview no I'm not
surprised the last thing I heard about
Jim Carrey's I he's playing that villain
in the Sonic the Hedgehog movie right so
that's somehow part of this so I was
getting interviewed for that movie when
he can make a small joke and twittered
took good pretty bad so I will show you
this clip and then the folk sonic has a
bucket list in your career and in your
life is that anything Stu left just you
[Music]
it's all done now did me just go [ __ ]
nuts for a minute too
and then like he started doing like
paint with his body and sure that was a
minute ago
well apparently his his he gave some
chicken STD and then she died I think
yeah that's when I started going way Jim
Carrey's counselor Oh cuz she killed
herself yeah Jenny McCarthy yes okay but
he gave her an STD first and I think
that part of that logic for why she
killed herself I guess is that she felt
like her life was over I was pretty
[ __ ] crazy so yeah I think that kind
of you know what STD mm-hmm do we know
what else I don't know I thought that's
just what I read and that interview just
seems like he's [ __ ] around all right
that's what a lot of people are saying
but then other people are saying that
this is like he's being a sleaze ball
and that and it's like very predatory
behavior and so it was really creepy
that he would use like his position over
her like that
that was [ __ ] well hey how's the
agents positioned oh it's like to me
it's like you even if it's him or Carrot
Top or whoever because I know they're a
comedian if they're just saying things
are just [ __ ] around if she's just
probably bored and goes what can I just
buy something
I think not to get his back or anything
it just feels like he's just he's just
trying to end those interviews later
there forever for all know that this is
probably like he's [ __ ] tenth one
that he did and they asked the exact
same [ __ ] question not to again
defend him how was the holiday I was
using his position to overpower because
of the second part that he said what he
says 'bonus own it but that's but he's
just it sounds like just he's keeping
the joke going on I don't know like that
I've never seen him do that kind of
humor really but how many times have you
really seen them interviewed of yeah we
don't we don't know those interviews of
it I see the comedian side standing a
bit keeping it going edit that [ __ ] out
well I mean if if this is a story
they're gonna release it they could get
some traction and lead back to the
website well it was actually the girl
who tweeted out the interview and how
did she feel about that's what I was
trying to find out because now her
Twitter account is private I don't even
know what it was that she said or how
she has responded to the responses so
I'm not too sure but she was the one who
ended up posting the interview on
Twitter so she posted the interview she
obviously I mean maybe she posted like
y'all this fucked-up thing happened or
she's like here's my interview Jim
Carrey yeah that's the thing I don't
know yeah actually yeah I really want I
think that that stuff so important right
because then it's like if she herself is
just like whatever I posed I was
interviewing Jim Carrey what do I expect
to happen he's gonna [ __ ] around
yeah like or or not or maybe she's like
yo this offended the [ __ ] I felt very
intimidated by that moment right yeah
and then even then it's a two-way street
every time right so a person could feel
a certain way but that doesn't mean that
the person [ __ ] intended their or
intended that yeah it's how she
perceived it as well cuz it could also
be she just wasn't smart enough or witty
enough to come back with something first
as any other reporter might have been
haha just kidding
what for real so what's the real bucket
list thing like not be able to turn it
and exactly that part right there and I
think that Jim is seasoned enough to
tell like like I understand again
standing a bit but I also understand
like the laugh I don't know what to say
after that I feel like it was his it was
on him at that point to say I'm just
kidding
my bucket list this yeah it's a back in
for
yeah because because you are the
seasoned actor and because you are who
you are it's your job to make like it
sucks but it's your job to make other
people comfortable in that situation
that will possibly be blown out like
this especially when it comes to
journalists because women have so many
barriers and it's [ __ ] to hop over
anytime something like this happens
that's how people are gonna see even
even though we all think I mean pretty
sure that he didn't mean it when any
like it will it could still come off
like that because I don't know if y'all
remember I think was a Morgan Freeman
interview it was him and so Jack
Nicholson it was a was it might have
been bucket list it might have been it
did that Hobie bucket list and that the
three of them are on the terrace and
there's a young lady interviewing them
and Morgan Freeman the whole time but
you could tell like yo you're being a
creepy old man like it was it was crazy
and for me you can't be Jesus and now
you're trying to [ __ ] these women like
what are you doing so he wasn't Jesus he
was God
well me either way that's even more
reason is there is there is but he's
still the son of the Father that's all
I'm saying point I'm trying to make is
he the father of the son what what are
you talking about see you trying to
distract the son became the father the
father Kinnison right out it to here you
just gotta okay no real quick just to
help just help out the other side of
this right so there's another side of
this to which is take Jim Carrey's
entire [ __ ] history into account well
he says this this isn't just like a
one-off with Morgan Freeman right where
Morgan Freeman had a bunch of incidents
including that time where he gave a girl
an STD and he's a nun womanizer Oh like
Jim here I'm kind of known for being a
womanizer
why well you're kind of thing isn't so
yeah
I was about to bring up another one
where he was blasted for the fur making
some creepy comments about more Margot
Robbie's looks on the Graham Norton Show
yes exactly so she ended up saying
you're really something margot robbie
it's incredible you got as far as you
have with your obvious physical
disadvantages that's pure talent there
he also made you remember he made a
[ __ ] weird video for own I think was
Margot Robbie it was so it was somebody
up-and-coming an actress like a
beautiful actress and he made a video
talking about her and how he wants to
get to know her and [ __ ] and put that
all over social media too so that's one
saying so when so almost all of you who
were judging me in the beginning of a do
I [ __ ] was talking about one thing
right but the other side of this thing
is that there's a tapestry of rich
history of Jim Carrey kind of doing this
custom and so maybe I think that's
factoring into people just judging this
moment and be like here he goes again I
see yeah Shannon I wasn't aware of all
that other stuff too but like I always
think like when you're this seasoned
person in a situation it's your
responsibility to either conduct
yourself attack or make people feel
comfortable to a certain degree and like
especially if you that would feel the
reason for the unsettledness like that
comment now you could tell she was
obviously taking a bag the shoes like I
think also if you'd like take
professionalism into account where if
the goal for all these press releases is
to sell the movie you should also have
that on your mind what is the best way
to answer all these questions to make
people want to come see the movie should
be like you know but that was is another
question do you think he told her that
he would be there as six and then didn't
show god damn it good point it's a good
point it's a good joke I don't get it
wait he's making [ __ ] up you know him oh
so sonic I mean you know Sonic the
Hedgehog he's a fast hedgehog right like
maybe he could have incorporated
something like that into the joke you
know I mean I'm like something to sell
the film's a pun or something yeah yeah
well make himself likable so people go
oh now I remember how much I loved Jim
Carrey I have to go watch this much he
was a villain in that movie so maybe he
was playing that right
a method actor he was stealing character
yeah like a deal with a Grinch no nuts
on that that's what I'm saying it's part
of his rich history of going [ __ ]
nuts he sat there with Andy Kaufman's
daughter and acted like he was really
Andy Kaufman and then told the cameras
about how he thought he gave Andy
Kaufman's daughter a beautiful final
moment with his with her so he channeled
Andy Kaufman through him that's what he
says right but it's like you just you
just try you're just making yourself
look like a god of acting right now I'm
going like I even gave him her daughter
like a final moment with her father like
[ __ ] weird [ __ ] I mean but they mean
that that movie was crazy to the point
like the director said he was
uncomfortable with Andy being on set
because he would only like when they
were family Jim Carrey would only answer
to Andy on set and he wouldn't answer to
Jim at all it was the craziest like he's
really a method act that he really dives
way into it so uh Jim Carrey's rep said
this this is a ridiculous non-story
Jim's full quote was just you that's it
I'm all done now clearly and
good-naturedly referring to the
interview as being on the top of his
bucket list it was in no way a reference
to the journalist herself this is
another example of a clip clickbait
headline pandering to the dark side of
scroll culture a dirty business done by
and for people with a dirty mind please
this weekend what was the contact she's
saying that the that the just you that's
it I'm all done now is referring to the
interview well right though that that
makes sense cuz he said I'm all done now
he didn't [ __ ] her yeah maybe she was
the last interview yeah is it the way it
was edited then how does the rep like
explain the the [ __ ] just own it that
part was create the creepiest part to me
so we'll play it again okay
was it like because it was an innuendo
so it could be taken two ways or I don't
know the rap is saying it's not like
don't take it that way the rep is just
saying he was just referring to the
interview like let's say she would she's
everything for entertainment tonight
he's just saying my last bucket list was
to be on Entertainment Tonight just
saying just you just you just support
just Jordan the rep is saying but I've
got all these dirty minds are taking it
as I want to I want to get you the girl
and there she's like no that's not how
he meant it
yeah you're the one watch it again one
more time you've done in your career and
in your life is there anything still
left on your bucket list just you it's
all done now the way geeks executed it
sometimes like you yeah cuz you you're
my last [ __ ] trophy girl when he said
it's all done now like if he had said it
like it's all done now like I would take
it as that interview but he was like
just you yeah it would be like you're
the last one yeah in this interview and
I'm all done right at least yeah but
it's not you're not gonna have to hear
in the [ __ ] interview not saying the
perfect guy says elected the next line
is gonna be do you know how rich I am I
gotta watch the whole thing I just leave
them know what the [ __ ] is if you look
at all the things you can carry did then
this is just another thing where I'm not
surprised but if you just look at this
then you all didn't find it silly so I
think I gotta get both it's like I'm
looking at a [ __ ] blue and gold dress
okay and something's like I think it's
white and golden items like I think it's
blue and black it's the same [ __ ]
[Music]
[Music]